bonjour Jean-Louis brugerre merci
beaucoup d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ancien jus spécialisé dans la
lutte antiterroriste on est avec vous
pendant une vingtaine de minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par
Stéphane Vernet deouest France bonjour
Stéphane bonjour Arian Jean-Louis
brugard bonjour bonjour bonjour et on va
évidemment parler de ce qui s'est passé
samedi soir à Paris he et de cette
attaque au couteau qui a eu lieu faisant
un mort de blessés l'assaillant qui
était suivi par le renseignement qui
avait fait de la prison pour préparation
d'une attaque terroriste qui était
également suivi psychiatriquement Gérald
haranan estime que les autorités ont
fait le maximum dans le cadre de la loi
mais quiil a eu un ratage psychiatrique
vous partagez son analyse en partie
euh oui il n'y a il y a eu si vous
voulez il n'y a pas eu de de faute
d'erreur ou de faille dans le dispositif
actuel tel qu'il existe à la fois
judiciaire et
administratif tout a été fait le procur
National antioriste l'a rappelé on va
pas revenir en fait il a été condamné à
5 ans d'emprisonnement pour des faits
donc terroristes donc quatre donc faire
mise à l'épreuve il y a cette mis à
l'épreuve d'un an qui a permis donc de
prendre des mesures probatoires de suivi
à la suite il y a eu le relais qui a été
fait par la DG si dans le cadre de la
loi et et des dispositions qui ont été
faites je ne sais pas si le Mik s été
mis en œuvre ou non donc l'ensemble des
dispositifs on été fait on été jusqu'au
moment où donc il a été il a possibilité
légale de faire autre chose alors la
partie la partie psychiatrique moi je ne
là je ne partage pas je suis plus
prudent que que que le ministre de
l'Intérieur pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que je ne suis pas psychiatre et
que je ne sais pas aujourd'hui c'est
quand même compliqué je pense pas que
monsieur dermanin a plus de compé que
moi ou d'autres il y a peut-être des
informations mais c'est quand même au
médecin quand même à à sinon pas
substituer à dire si il y a eu ça moi je
peux pas meer d'autre part de faire un
lien mécanique je trouve ça très
dangereux entre donc un profil
psychiatrique et une pathologie et le
passage à l'acte donc terroriste tel que
je connais me paraît me paraît très
actif parce que ça se passe pas
nécessairement comme ça moi j'ai eu des
profils psychiatrique l' intéresser
d'après ce que pu avoir notamment il a
un témoignage très intéressant pour ur
Pelou qui était là qui est intervenu pr
intervenant et cetera et qui a été
frappé par la précision excusez-moi du
geste donc de l'intéressé qui était
quand même une maîtrise de soi et qui
connaissait malheureusement très bien
quelles étaient les les parties donc qui
étaient qu'il fallait toucher pour
arriver donc à à ce but d'autre part
détermination extrême alors pe s'inire
une pathologie d'autre part il a été
établi moi je connais pas le dossier
mais c'est c'est l'formation ouverte que
j'ai pu glaner donc au cours de de ce
que j'ai pu entendre sur les chaînes ou
ailleurs que l'intéressé avait pratiqué
ce qu'on appelle atakia moi je connais
bien c'est dire la dissimulation et que
il a fait à croire à tout le monde que
il était
déradicalisé très contre et cetera et
cetera et cetera donc donc ce qui
n'était pas et que la prison l'avait
déradicalisé voilà ce quiétait pas le
cas alors il y a eu bien sûr l'alerte de
la merre mais mais la lerre de la mer du
rest pénaté procureur nation l'a bien
décidé moi je et bien évidment tous ces
éléments nétaient des éléments
insuffisants pour pouvoir être
constiutif d'une infraction pénale
quelconque y compris une nation de
malfaiteur à caractère terroriste donc
il n'y avait pas si vous voulez de de
possibilité légale de neutralisation
hormi des suivis voilà voilà donc donc
on est on est incontestablement arrivé
au bout du bout alors évidemment
évidemment je veux dire il y a eu un
attentat donc donc il y a un problème il
y a donc ça pose question on va parler
Stéphan que que ça ça c'est évident que
ça fa juste un dernier mot sur le côté
psychiatrique parce que Gérald armanin
dit souhaiter que les autorités puissent
prononcer une injonction de soins ce qui
n'est pas le cas actuellement est-ce que
pour vous c'est une bonne piste écoutez
je n'en sais rien c'est une bonne
question le problème savoir si
l'injonction de soins et d'abord un est
médicalement nécessaire est-ce que vous
vous accepteriez qu'on fasse une
injenction de soins donc sera une
pathologie quelconque c'est quand même
un problème bon mais effectivement on
est dans des profils avec des gens
dangereux on peut faire les injonctions
de soins comme on le fait en matière
psychiatrique pour des gens qui sont
psychiatriquement dangereux donc le
problème se pose pas première chose
deuxième chose toujours le même problème
est-ce que cette injonction de so cé
aurait eu aurait eu un effet mais je
veux dire aurait empêché cette attentat
voilà la question que je pose moi moi
moi j'en suis pas certain euh et et et
et le problème le problème qui se pose
qui est un problème plus politique mais
dans je dirais avec un grand pai hein
pas politicien je pas du tout qu'on
instrumentalise tout ça c'est est-ce que
nous pouvons aller plus loin donc pour
éviter que des profils de ce genre dont
on sait qu' sont voilà alors justement
on on peut ou pas vous avez vous avez
cité le le l'association de malfaiteurs
terroristes il y a un instant ça c'est
une notion qui a été introduite dans le
loit en France en par une loi en 1996
c'est quand même un dispositif qui va
très loin parce que elle permet de
sanctionner très durement la préparation
d'actes de terrorisme avant même qu'il
ne soit commis là il me semble que dans
même que l'auteur ne connaît pas euh
l'existence de de de d'un crime ou d'un
délit ou ou ou d'un projet terrorist
vous alle vous allez me corriger si je
me trompe mais dans le dans le cas du de
l'attentat de de birakim samedi on
apprend aujourd'hui que le l'auteur
aurait été en contact avec l'assassin de
Samuel pati en
2020 donc après sa sortie de prison
pourquoi est-ce que là on n pas on
écoutez juridiquement c'était pas
possible pourquoi pourquoi ben parce que
les éléments si vous voulez on va pas
faire un débat juridique sur la MT et
Dieu sait si moi je l'ai pratiqué
pendant des années des années des années
et et d'une façon très extensive mais là
si vous voulez il fallait il aurait
fallu qu'on fasse qu'on fasse si vous
voulez des
perquisitions depuis la loi de
2017 SC le permet on aurait pu le faire
bon mais qui aurait pu permettre d'avoir
à cel effectivement la loi 2017 on va y
revenir donc permet qui est une loi
alors il faut quand même dire à tout le
monde fait ici les hommes politiques les
connaissent mais cette loi 2017 qui est
partie après 2015 a permis d'introduire
dans le droit commun donc des dispos de
l'état d'urgence de façon à péréniser
l'état d'urgence sans avoir recourir à
cette loi d'è comp et je veux dire elle
est sans précédent en Europe donc on a a
un instrument qui est utilisé et qui
suppose aussi l'accord du JLD du juge de
la liberté de la détention qui très
souvent donc un juriste peuvent dire
attendez les éléments que vous me donnez
pour nous ne sont pas suffisamment
pertinents et du reste le préfetunu a
indiqué que quelque fois le JLD ne les
avait pas suivi dans des requêtes qui a
été faite pour des des visites
domiciliaires a des perquisitions donc
donc donc là si vous voulez mais moi je
vous parle en tant que que juriste les
éléments tels que j'avais
et le monsieur le procureur national
antiroriste qui est quand même un
magistrat qui est qui est en plus il il
était à la Cour de cassation avant il a
il a à la Chambre criminelle donc donc a
estimé à juste titre que les éléments
n'étaient pas en l'état réunis pour
pouvoir à l'époque mais attendez le
pouvoir donc euh ouvrir une information
en
tout faire engager des poursuites du
chef
defit 4221 du code pénal donc vous êtes
en train de nous dire qu'il y a eu
aucune défaillance il y a pas eu il y a
pas eu d'erreurs il y a pas eu du reste
je crois je crois qu' je je je crois que
si vous voulez le le le tout le monde
est d'accord là-dessus alors sauf la la
dimension psychiatrique mais moi qui est
une qui est polmque un peu polémique et
sur laquelle moi je veux pasengager
parce que j'estime que j'ai pas la
compétence pour ça
qu'est-ce alors ça ça pose quand même
une question c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire de alors si vous voulez non mais
c'est vrai qu'il faut faire quelque
chose ENF faire quelque chose non mais
je veux dire je comprends je comprends
que l'opinion publique d'une part et et
et et et et je veux dire les
parlementaires politique la question est
posée sur la table alors on va pas
sortir de la polémique politicienne des
uns et des autres c'est pas le sujet ici
il y Ava effectivement le le sujet qui
est la possibilité c'est comment
neutraliser on a la possibilité de le
faire par exemple pour pour pour pour
des délinquants sexuels et cetera il il
y a une disposition spécifique mais qui
ne peut pas être étendue à cela il y a
eu une proposition qui a été faite pour
pouvoir faire une réation administrative
dans ce domaine qui n'a pas qui été
retoqué pour des RA par leel parce que
alors d'un vous disent il faut cettetion
de sé changer la constitution c'est
quand même une aventure
importante surtout dans dans
l'architecture je veux dire donc
politique actuelle pas certain qu'on y
arrive et il faut aussi que comprendre
que une loi de ce genre n'est pas
rétroactive elle peut pas être pour
l'avenir non mais est-ce que pour vous
alors c'est pas rétroactif effectivement
mais est-ce que cette question de la
rétention de chté c'est-à-dire que qu'on
puisse continuer à mettre des gens en
prison une fois la peine exécuté SS sont
Dang j'ai réfléchi un peu la question
voilà un peu première pour pour l'excéat
parce que je pas dit à personne je pense
qu'on pourrait peut-être c'est peut-être
faire
évoluer les dispositions légales sur le
mic les mesures donc ind iduel de
contrôle administratif de sécurité qui
prévoit déjà des mesures de contrainte
importantes qui vont aller même jusqu'au
bracelet électronique dans certaines
conditions valable 3 mois jusque dans la
limite d'un an et je me disais que par
si vous voulez en en repassant un petit
peu par la loi 2017 que vous avez cité
que je connais bien et notamment qui
permet des des visites domiciliaires
donc des mesures qui sont très
attentatoir la liberté individuelle et
qui ne peuvent être ordonné là pour le
coup on passe jaune que par l'autorité
judiciaire ou s un contrôle judiciaire
la preuve c'est que c'est le JLD
pourquoi on ne pourrait pas imaginer
donc un dispositif permettant donc des
mesures beaucoup plus contraignantes en
faisant l'voluicace du style assignation
résidence voir même réation
administrative sous contrôle judiciaire
c'est-à-dire avec une autorisation
préalable de jus de la liberté de la
détention pour une durée donnée et avec
un contrôle permanent l'intéressé
pouvant demander au juges la levée de la
mesure ou non là je ne pense pas que le
Conseil cons s opposerait parce que
là pour le coup on serait plus dans un
on aurait un contrôle judiciaire c'est
ça la difficulté ou mais alors
excusem juste ça c'est possible sans
toucher à la constitution c'est une
évolution l 2017 n'a pas été retoquée
une perquisition c'est quand même une
mesure débouler chez vous à 6h du
matin il faut il faut il faut qu'il y a
un mandat juste une observation si vous
me permettez j'ai cru comprendre aussi
que dans le cas de l'attentat de d'aras
le 13 octobre le l'assassin de Dominique
Bernard a fait l'objet d'une visite
domiciliaire la veille de de son passage
à l'acte donc ça montre que aussi que ce
ce l'ensemble de ce ce même si on a un
arsenal qui a été fortement renforcé et
cetera qui qui donne beaucoup d'outils
qui met beaucoup d'outils à disposition
là on voit que dans les deux des deux
attentats qui viennent de se produire on
n pas affaire à des loups solitaires des
gens don qui passent à l' sans aucun ça
n'existe plus on est d'accord là ce sont
des fichiers s des gens qui étaient qui
étaient dans les radars et cetera qui
étaient quand même suivi or force de
constater que ça ne fonctionne pas ça
les empêche pas de passer à l'acte donc
il manque y a bien quelques chose qui
manque alors si vous voulez il y a deux
choses il y a le recueil du
renseignement là c'est important il y a
de c'est la capacité que l'on a
aujourd'hui etilà on l'a déjà renforcé
d'avoir une possibilité de recueillir
des signaux très faibles à basse
intensité très tôt ça c'est
crucial le lien entre les différents
services c'est beaucoup amélioré ces
dernières années vous l'avez dit à pluss
reprises moi moi j'ai connu quand
j'étais aux affaires entre Guill est-ce
est-ce qu'il serait pas temps
aujourd'hui d'utiliser par exemple
exemple des logiciels de passer à
l'intelligence artificielle pour
interpréter ces signaux faibles que vous
décrivez oui comme vous savez la loi
2017 autorise précisément l'intelligence
artificielle pas dans des conditions
très particulières dans très encadré
notamment sur les interceptions
électroniques c'est surtout la DG ce qui
le fait des moyens et cetera et puis moi
je peux vous dire là que la la les les
relations qui existent entre des grands
services notamment les services
américains qui ont des capacité comme la
NSA donc très super au nôes question de
moyen ou les Britanniques et cetera et
est très forte il y a la communauté
internationale du renseignement
fonctionne dans ce domain là
particulièrement très bien mais est-ce
qu'on a un peu du mal à comprendre Jean
brug peut-être naïvement c'est que ces
gens ils sont repérés par les services
de renseignement ils sont suivis là vous
l'avez dit il y a pas eu de faille dans
le suivi et pourtant il regarde le
dispositif ouis des dispositifs existant
et et pourtant il passent à l'acte alors
qu'est-ce qui manque est-ce que ce sont
des moyens dans le renseignement ou
est-ce que c'est ailleurs que çache non
mais vous savez attendez la nature
humaine c'est moi moi j'ai vu moi j'ai
quand même une longue expérience c'était
pas à l'époque c'était pas ces gens
cétait plus facile parce qu'ils étaient
dans des réseaux structurés et cetera
pas comme aujourd'hui mais vous avez
quand même des gens qui sont le passage
à l'acte est quelque chose de très
individuel il y a un individu tout d'un
coup qui dit je passe à l'âge et pas ou
pas du tout demain on arrive à un
secteur où effectivement le problème de
la décision est quelque chose de de de
de très compliqué très personnel
euh très fugace très aléatoire dans
alors ce qu'il a c'est qu'on disamine
des profils donc des PO potialité ça
voilà celui-là il a des potentialités
extrêmes d'un jour ou l'autre passer à
l'acte mais de déterminer que tel hôtel
va passer l'acte demain à 18h à tel
endroit non c'est très compliqué voilà
mais ça veut dire qu'il y a une forme
d'impuissance comment ça veut dire qu'il
y a une forme
d'impuissance il y a à ce niveau-là sauf
sauf si vous voulez effectivement la
neutralisation très compliquée parce
qu'on peut pasà c'est des des méthodes
alors c'est vrai que si vous avez un
suivi extrêmement serré plus le suivi
est serré plus les informations plus si
vous voulez les les capacités que
l'individu entre guillemets vous échappe
ou passe à l'acte sont plus faibles
c'est incontestable mais mais euh hormi
si vous voulez le le le l'arétention
administrative c'est-à dire en fait un
emprisonnement ou une neutralisation
donc dans un dans un milieu clos et
fermé euh je vois pas non le aujourd'hui
l'arsenal alors l'arsenal peut évoluer
mais mais est-ce qu'il faut le faire
évoluer parce que c'est aussi la
question c'est que là on est sur une
ligne de crête entre l'état de droit
li libertés et en même temps assurer la
sécurité des citoyens est-ce qu'il faut
faire évaluer est-ce qu'il faut accepter
libertés pour assurer pas moi je veux
dire al parce que ça là je suis très
ferme je me suis fait insulter sur un
plateau peu importe c'est pas grave mais
en tout cas je pense moi je suis on ne
peut pas renoncer àre État de droit ça
c'est vraiment fondamental il faut quand
même voir en tout cas les G d'alqa
parceon a trouvé des documents une
époque av poussé par des provocations
pour pouss d'État à sortir de l'état de
droit et justement à tir de notre
argumentation et notre justification
c'est l' objectif des terroristes des
objectifs des terroristes c'est un
objectif donc il faut être très vigilant
alors évidemment dans la classe
politique dans C il y a des gens qui
poussent aux extrêmes et moi je dirais
non bon alors d'autant plus d'autant
plus que et là je revient la France est
le pays en Europe qui est le plus on
nous a suffisamment critiqué la MT a
donné lieu à de fortes critiques au sein
du Conseil de l'Europe et cetera nos
dispositifs la loi de 2017 est fortement
critiqué forcé de constater que il y a
pas un pays qui fait des qui fait des
perquisitions administratives donc bon
même même avec un contrôle Judici on a
quand même un gros problème enfin
j'insiste mais on sait qu'on il y a eu
beaucoup d'affaires de terrorisme dans
les années 90 au début des années 2000
il y a plein de gens qui ont été
condamnés pour des faits de terrorisme
pour les associations de malfaiteurs
terroristes qui aujourd'hui ont purgé
leur peine même quand son sont des pein
long longues qui sont sortis ou qui vont
commencer à sortir est-ce que vous avez
une idée du nombre comme ça de de gens
qui étaient radicalisés tique moi si
vous voulez moi j'ai été aux affaires
enfin je me suis occupé de terroris
vraiment depuis 95 92 avec l'affaire du
Groupe islamique armé du GIA les
attentats à Paris dans le métro après le
groupe GSPC après l'ACMI toutes C
organisations l'alkaïda est-ce que tous
ces gens sont qui sont sortis de prison
le tger leur peine est-ce qu'ils sont
bien suivisd ils vont moi je suis pas
des prisons euh il y en a qui prennent
des des peine de 20 ans 25 ans 30 ans et
cetera bon ou moins bon il est évident
moment jour un un jour ou l'autre ils
vont sortir bon alors il y a le facteur
aussi âge important les pinees longue
euh à 20 ans on n' pas les mêmes
comportements qu'à 50 il y a aussi la
question des programmes de
déradicalisation en prison est-ce que ça
marche ça alors moi je peux pas vous le
dire parce que je les connais mal comme
ça je ne suis pas l'intérieur c'est très
compliqué moi moi j'ai à l'époque les
programmes n'existaient pas ou tu était
moins évolué par contre j'en ai vu à
l'étranger j' mêmeu en Arabie Saoudite
et qui fonctionne Arabie saite ça
fonctionne pas trop mal parce que on est
dans un milieu si vous voulez différent
et où il y a la pression culturelle la
pression je veux
dire religieuse et cetera qui fait que
ces individus ils ils ont des moyens
ouais nous c'est compliqué parce que on
n pas la légitimité est faible on n pas
on n pas des voilà donc déjà c'est très
compliqué un pays des pays
musulmans qui ont des Mo en des
capacités certainement supérieur de
déradicalisation pour ces gensl parce
que attention parce qu'il y en a
d'autres qui ne sont pas dont le le
substratum éologique n'est pas le mêmeou
et ce que jeallis vous demander parce
que vous connaissez les profils de ces
gensl est-ce qu'ils peuvent se
déradicaliser vraiment moi j'ai vu par
exle des gens complètement différents de
la r fraction la fraction mer Rouge je
dire impossible à réicaliser ce sont des
espèces de fou dangereux impossible ils
sont dans une violence permanente moi
j'aiété agressé en des gens fallait
sauter dessus c'était c'est pas les
mêmes voilà alors ça dépend des gens
vousz bon et après vous avez d'autres
gens indépendantistees problèm de plan
des mou Corse tout à fait calme pas TR
de souci bon là aussi les choses
évoluent bon regardez par exemple c'est
très intéressant parce que vous sa je me
suis beaucoup occupé d'action directe
qui était un mouvement leuroterrorisme
qui est lié à la RAF était la briade
rouge et on s'est aperçu après que céit
mouvement étaiit complètement manipulé
par l'Allemagne de l'Est et par les les
services et quand le le mur sécroulé
tout ça a disparu donc pas eu voilà
est-ce que le le contexte international
joue aussi l'assadion il aurait évoqué
ce qui se passe en Israël est-ce que ça
peut augmenter le nombre de passages à
l'ACT tout tout à fait incontestablement
si vous voulez en substratum c'est une
une récupération une manipulation une
exacerbation ces individus quel que soit
leur profil mental psychologique
psychiatrique sont très sensibles donc à
à à ces phénomènes et et à la propagande
qui est faite par les organisations sur
la problématique manquenne donc les ce
sont dans les l'Occident contre contre
les musulmans et il est évident que ça
crée un climat qui est favorable à des
passages à l'ct c'est propagande elle
passe en grande partie aujourd'hui par
les réseaux sociaux est-ce que est-ce
qu'il faut les réguler d'autorité alors
là je pense je pense là oui je suis
d'accord avec vous la seule chose c'est
est-ce que l' le problème c'est que
aussi juridiquement ces réseaux sont pas
pilotés depuis la
France et que donc les moyens juridiques
que l'on a sont compliqués voilà bon
mais je pense qu'on pourrait y avoir par
un accord européen là-dessus comme on
l'a fait par ailleurs supprimer tous les
comptes pour pour pour
avoiry pression mettre mettre en place
aussi avej les États-Unis les Américains
sont sont concernés par ça même si bon
Twitter devenu X et détenu par un
personnage qui est hyper libéral mais
mais au bout un moment il une
responsabilité moi je pense qu'on peut
agir oui oui on l'a déjà fait juste
parce qu' on a appris que la saant avait
fait allégance à l'état islamique c'est
ce qu'a dit le procureur antiterroriste
est-ce que aujourd'hui l'État islamique
il continue à suciter des vocations oui
tout à fait il est très actif alors
l'état islamique si vous voulez a changé
jusqu'au moment si vous voulez il était
un proto-état euh première fois et puis
après après les actions don donc menées
par les Américains et les Français la
destruction là pour le coup deétat
islamique l'État islamique a fait
exactement comme comme fait Alka c'est
il a il a il a il s'est mis été vouit en
filial partout dans le monde vous en
avez donc l'état islamique dans le Grand
Sahara le js qui est très actif au côté
d'Al-Qaïda vous l'avez en Afrique de
l'est également en Afrique centrale vous
l'avez en Afghanistan vous l'avez au au
en Syrie en Irak donc en Asie du reste
avec la Jama islamia enfin du moins les
les les les les groupes qui ont été pris
certains faisant allégance à can
d'autres l'État islamique donc donc il
s'est planétarisé un côté pas est-ce que
du coup vous êtes inquiet il y a les
jeux olympique qui arri vous êtes
inquiet pour la sécurité des gios
écoutez je suis inquiet ça être inquiet
je je suis inquiet comme comme t les bon
moi je pense que c'est un événement
planétaire il serait passé dans autre
pays les responsables des autres pays
aurit été aussi inquiet donc du fait de
la nature de l'événement pense que aussi
tout a été mis en œuvre je veux dire moi
je fais quand même confiance à nos
gouvernants donc surtout moi Stéphane
vous avez une dernière question oui une
dernière question qui sur un tout autre
thème une question d'actualité vous avez
été tenté par la politique il y a
quelques années vous vous étiez présenté
aux élection législative en 2007 dans la
3e circonscription du lotgaron vous avez
été battu à l'époque au second par un
certain Jérôme Cusac tout à fait ce
dernier a annoncé la semaine dernière
qu'il voulait revenir en politique
est-ce que ça vous ins écoutez j'ai fait
cette
expérience je regrette reg regter de
l'avoir fait parce que j'étais pas fait
pour faire de la politique la politique
c'est un métier et j'ai pensais qu'on
pouvait passer une espèce de vision donc
très idéale du service public de l'un à
l'autre et je me suis rendu compte que
c'était pas ça et je dois dire
que lors de la campagne Jér a été très
dur mais correct je pas voilà très très
d'autres d'omes politiques l'ont é té
mooins y compris et compris ceux qui
auraient dû me soutenir mais ça bon qui
B on a envie de savoir non sur son
retour en politique vous saurez pas
parce que je vais pas faire de polémique
la seule chose que je trouve que je
retire de positif c'est que la campagne
est
passionnante m'a permis de voir un petit
peu de voir regarder un peu dans les
petites communes la réalité moi qui
avait été quand même dans dans une
vision plutôt stratosphérique et et
globale c'est intéressant voilà vous me
répondez qu'à moitié sur le retour de
J écoutez pourquoi pas moi je sa
responsabilité donc il a il a il a
plongé sa peine il a tout fait bon bon
il va se il ve il veut il a apparemment
il aime la politique il est pas le seul
il veut se présenter au souffrage des
électeurs bon je veux
direanch moi je pas j'ai pas de j'ai pas
d'opinion particulière euh à exprimer
sur le retour qui je trouve qu'il a il a
il a une capacité mégatique quand même
très très forte
voilà ser parle de lui on en parle
aujourd'hui voilà merci jeanl bruger
merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité
Stéphane la Une de wouest France et la
COP quel bilan mondial pour les
émissions de CO2 c'est à la Une de votre
journal merci beaucoup Stéphane à la
semaine prochaine merci Jean-Lou bruger
on passe au club de territoire